okay hey everyone it's Michael Volos
here from orderflows decom and this is
the orderflows market analysis for
Monday May 15 2017 I apologize if I
sound uh my voice sounds much deeper
today I'm still fighting this very bad
cold that I've had for quite a while um
every time it goes away it comes back
but um S&P is Rose today um we closed uh
we closed higher and you know we're
approaching on the future side at least
we're approaching our basically our
alltime high which was made just after
the French election and let me just get
the daily chart up here for you really
quick if I can find it here we go
um you know after the French elections
we got up here to uh what was that like
03 and 3/4 today the Futures we got up
to believe was two and a quarter so very
very close in the evening session we're
training a little bit lower that's fine
um you know we we'll see if we can get
some follow through later today
now um you know the housing numbers you
know if you've been following the
numbers again you know I'm I don't claim
to be an economist so when I talk about
numbers you know it's just my own
personal thoughts I'm definitely not a
classical trained Economist in that
sense and you know I don't claim to be
and you know but I do look at the
numbers because you know again I'm
curious but housing has been emerging as
basically the economy best surprise this
year I think and you know it's been
showing strength all all year long and
you know this this uh most recent
numbers have been coming out you know is
showing strength in firsttime buyers
which I think is is very important
because you know that's been scarce I
mean you know it's one thing you know
people buying second homes or you know
things like that you know investment
homes but you know really what you want
to have is you want to have you know
firsttime buyers be coming into the
markets
and excuse
me so you know that said that said uh
let's uh get jumping into this
uh analysis for today uh first the
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered solicitation to
buy or sell Futures Contract or Mak it a
type of investment decision Futures
training contains substantial risk it's
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all the more than the
initial Capital risk capital is money
that can be lost without risking one's
Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk Capital should be used for trading
only those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
reason results again you know your
trading is going to be different than my
trading you know I I teach people how to
trade but I don't expect them to be you
know copies of me trading you know
everyone every Trader is different and
you know there's going to be things that
resonate with you that I talk about and
things that make no sense that you that
you just don't grasp or you think ah
Mike you know he's crazy he's a crazy
fool you know he's get a tinf foil hat
for him but you know hopefully in my
discussions you know in these videos
that I put out
you'll find something that you'll say
yeah that makes perfect sense now I can
understand the markets better and that's
really why I do it so you know for all
you haters out there just keep on hating
um the tools use in this presentation
are the old flows Trader the Delta
scalper and I I do talk about other
other indicators here and there um you
know once in a while but the main ones
I'm using in this presentation is
obviously the orderflows trader which is
the footprint chart and my proprietary
indicator the delta scalper so talking
about the Delta
scalper let's take a look now there were
some interesting things this is a
Japanese Yen and this is just the night
session you get right on the high in the
night session 655 Chicago time you do
get a sell but again I don't Advocate
training during the asan session if if
you don't have to you if that's the only
time you got to then you know no choice
I do think it's a little bit difficult
and that comes from experience you know
I've lived in Asia and I've I've worked
that that training time you know I've
been there from the reopen for eight
years I literally traded the reopen of
of I say Globex I people don't refer to
as Globex anymore but basically the
reopen of Globex until mid European
session I did that for eight years so I
know when the markets are lackluster
when there's not a lot of going on
and when the markets are active and
again if you had your choice of
trading you know during the trading day
you know what's the best time to trade
obviously during if you're trading us
markets during the US hour hours second
would be uh the early morning the
European hours and and lastly would be
Asian hours especially um you know
sometimes it's like watching paint dry
honestly um there's no other way to put
it so but anyway you know
speaking of the Asian session or sorry
the European session give me a sec okay
so this was the Del Delta scoper this
morning in Europe European session 2: in
the morning you had a buy here but it's
a red candle so you really shouldn't be
looking at take it again you know why
are you looking to buy when the price
action of the bar is down you shouldn't
be but then at the low of the day 8803
and a half you get the Delta scalper
given another buy here is the Delta
surge given a
sell okay again you know I've talked at
length about you know taking things in
context of the market after you have a
big sell off and then you get you know
the Delta surge given a sell is that the
best place to take it no what would you
rather be doing buying off a low or
selling into a low yes you can go lower
but if you just had a big move from you
know higher level down into new lows to
get a sell signal it's probably not
going to be very effective what you
should be looking for is buying
signals I say buying signals CU people
are going to think oh use the red light
green light system no it's not you're
looking for signs in the market in the
order flow that the market is bottoming
out and is possibly getting ready for a
turn and you get it down here with the
Delta scalper giv a nice buy you got
some nice imbalances off this
low start rallying you go from 8
80 what is that 8808 you get all the way
up to 28 start to go sideways here so
this was a nice move here sorry I got to
pause I if this recording sounds sketchy
it's because I keep coughing okay so you
know then a little bit later now now you
get the Delta surge given a buy okay so
you're going sideways right and this is
why I came up with this Delta surge is
cuz in a market that's going sideways
like it is here you can't deny it's
going sideways poke lower you know
you're basically be trading between
29 and 20 then you start getting back up
towards the high of this range and you
get the Delta surge kickoff those are
the types of Trades you should be
looking to take not you know after you
sell off like here right you literally
come from your high straight down into
your lows low low low low lower and then
you get Delta surge right before the
bottom that's not where you want to be
taking it what you want to be taking it
is a market that's going sideways
ideally
this is when I developed
it it was because of this it was because
of markets going sideways you can't make
heads or tails of what's going on is
buying picking up or selling picking up
but you can see it in the Delta
increasing here and you get your signal
right there and you go from you know
basically 8830 all the way up to new
highs 8840 um you get a ratio right up
here at the high of the day you start
selling off from the high of the day
down into this area where you get this
Delta surge but again again it's on a
red bar you don't want to be taking it
if you know you don't get the
confirmation in the bar sort of comes
into this bottom starts turnning around
get Del a surge buy here doesn't wasn't
very great it just went sideways on you
um you know Buy Here Sell Here this one
you really wouldn't be interested in
taking you get the Delta surge there
going into the low yeah I don't know I'm
not a big fan of them I just don't find
them very effective going into the lows
or highs in the sense that you know
where we had just moved from a high from
much higher area I'd rather be taking
them you know after a period of
absorption a period of
congestion okay let see what else we got
here let's talk about the euro currency
here again Euro
currency we're in the evening session
right now you know very tight range it's
it's not advisable to be trading that
trading that
time let's just go back and bit
here okay so you did have this buying
inbalance here now you get to this bar
here point of control right at the top
you know I do find that bearish and it
just goes sideways on you over the next
three bars before coming back up and
taking out the highs um you know is
there any sign in here well you know
it's very very thin volume that's that's
one thing and you know this bar has got
278 volume uh which is nothing you know
normally These Bars got 800 and 1,000
here 1,800 1,500 but I'd be getting
worried say I got short off this bar I'd
be getting worried down here when you're
coming to this this bottom here where
you got some decent volume and when I
say decent
volume use your eyes you know look at
what's trading okay here you got 144 151
250 118 103 there is some supportive
buying in there there's no way you can't
deny that especially you know when
previously do you see any volume like
that here you got
195 that's it you know 139 160 that's it
there there's not much other volume in
here that's that stands out so you know
there's supportive volume coming in so
if you've been short and you're seeing
buying come down here you get out I'm
not saying get long but at least get
out okay so then we come up here we get
the the Delta scal we giving a sell but
it's not a green bar you you really
shouldn't be interested in taking those
um going sideways here another green bar
with the Delta scalper not really
interested here was a ratio um you know
at this high of the day there wasn't you
know at these highs there's no ratios
here you know here you got a fail
Divergence and here you got failed
Divergence here you got a fail
Divergence so you know when I start
seeing failed diverences I I do think
the market is going to start to to move
um move up if it's you know fail
divergences on the way up and we do um
get another one here then here know this
is a Delta scoper you should be looking
to take you should be looking to take
this you know here the bar confirms it
you know we close lower and you know we
do Trace back up to this High we test
the high okay but then you know we make
a move down finally um you know the here
just sort of going sideways sideways
nothing spectacular happening in
here you that brings us to where we are
right
now uh the next one I'll talk about is
beans I honestly I haven't looked at the
beans um in a couple well since since
this
morning so you know the first sign you
know 8:30 really is time should be
looking at
it and
8:37 you get this bar here Point control
right at the top you get a zero print
there again you know this is around that
time of of the reopening you know
Futures open at 8:30 and you know you
got to give it some time to work out and
often times you know within the first 5
minutes towards the end of the first 5
minutes this is 7 Minutes P you get this
and I if you've been watching my videos
for the last week you you'll see this
happen quite often is it actionable yes
it is you do get a little bit of a move
lower but nothing much to do so you get
fail Divergence fail Divergence fail
Divergence fail Divergence so if you
know again if you're just selling
divergences by themselves this one I
think is the only one that's actionable
these two
no no you know even though it doesn't
come back up but again you know be
careful selling any blind you know for
people say yeah you could have sold this
and made something yeah you could have
sold that made something yeah you could
have sold this and made
something you know what are you going to
make two or three ticks is that what you
want I mean if that's what you want then
yeah sure go for it but you know I'd
rather get um you know in in the
soybeans I'd rather get sents rather
than um you know quarter uh what do you
call it quarter uh ticks you know Moves
In cents but you know this four you know
goes 970 971 and a quarter 971 half I'd
rather get you know full cents rather
than the the the ticks
so you again you get this is the Stacked
in Balance
now is can you trade that yeah you can I
I much rather get the stacking balances
a little bit closer to the highs or you
know swing highs not after I mean in
this case you can make the argument that
you're sort of breaking down and going
lower okay you can do that um is it a
big move down no not
really you know it sort of goes nowhere
for the first five bars which you know
and at this point if you're
short if you're short this imbalance it
here you know you're thinking it's still
in your favor maybe you want to hold it
I don't know me at at this point by the
six bar if it's still just sort of
hanging around there I'd probably bail
out honestly um then we just go sideways
off this stacked and balance so nothing
special in in the soybeans again you
know why am i showing people are saying
scratching their head Mike why you
showing me this nothing happened well I
do do want you to see you know there are
times when nothing happens in the market
cuz people think that you know order
flow is going to pick every single
turning point in the market no it's it's
not it's going to find those areas
where you know where there's something
happening that that you can trade off of
and you know sometimes there's just
nothing happening in the markets you
know different markets got different you
know different
reactions this one I thought was
interesting this morning I remember
watching this and I looking at it we
come into this low down here at uh 7:30
you got a ratio you got the U price
rejector given a buy you don't have a
Divergence got a negative
Delta you do next bar you get the Delta
scalper given a buy and you just you
don't go anywhere you just start coming
down so this is about picking up what's
not happening you know everyone talks
about um you know where to get out of
trade trade
management is you know part of being a
good Trader is is managing your trade
and recognizing when it's not working
out you know so if you're getting long
off this in the next bar you got a
bullish sign but then this bar is down
it doesn't go any higher this bar is
down you know you get out you get out
here at at break even or even lose a
tick there's nothing wrong with losing a
tick would you rather lose the tick or
let it come down here and stop you out
you know you should take the tick rather
than the full stop
out then down here you get another uh
ratio with a D not another one this is a
ratio with a Divergence here is just a
Divergence again that's nothing here is
a Divergence with a
ratio and do you get a move yeah a
little bit nothing to WR home write home
about bonds interest rates well five
years at least we're we're pretty quiet
today and so let just move into the uh
into the bonds here then if I can find
them where' It Go
spart excuse me I'm
sorry so you know Bond's a little bit
different than the 5 years different but
similar and on here you don't have a you
don't have a ratio don't have a
Divergence you didn't have a Divergence
on the five years but you do get the
U-turn given a buy there just as you had
in the five years putting control
towards the bottom okay I'm not
necessarily convinced and here you get
the Delta scer given a buy yeah I'd
probably be more interested in that and
what does it do it just comes right back
down on you so you know you got to
recognize it's not working
out
here it's almost a ratio almost it's
73 um you get the U-turn given a buy you
get the ratio afterwards honestly I I
thought this one you know is interesting
I'm not going to say yeah I would take
it because then people say oh you know
can say and take it it doesn't have the
ratio that he likes though he's cherry
picking but whatever um again you know
the best computer there the one on your
head you know one of the problems
that you Traders I I think you know
struggle with is trying to be exact you
know um exactness kills
and you know training doesn't work that
way you know everybody wants to be exact
on where they enter exact on where they
exit
and you know that that's not to say that
you can't be exact you know but
sometimes you know you're reading the
market it keeps changing right it's
telling you different things and you
know the only way to be perfectly exact
is if you have your system fully
programmed that you know you're not even
involved in the decision making
basically you're there just to make sure
the the lights on and the system is
running as properly and doesn't blow up
on you um
but you but but really you know what
you're looking to do is you know make
the best I don't say guess but make the
best trade based on the information you
have at you and if it changes it changes
you know I mean people you know
sometimes you think well I got to either
let the trade stop me out or go to the
full profit no if it doesn't if it
changes you see here point of control
all line up right at the same level more
or less three at the same level one here
okay you know you're you're thinking at
this point you know you know if you're
getting long off this and you start
coming in here sideways you get out you
know then say I'm waiting you know we're
just consolidating I'm going to wait for
that move you wait for the move in this
case it came lower and would have
stopped you out you know what can you do
then down here you get the uh Divergence
don't get the ratio got the price
projector though then you get the ratio
afterwards so you got the Divergence
with the ratio afterwards and you get
the bar here one bar up basically um
going into the close
okay
eurocurrency did I talk about euro
currency already I I
did I think I
did um I want I want is crude
then sorry my my my brain isn't actually
acting proper I'm on a lot of cough
medicine and Vicks and all that sort of
stuff you could just hear my voices this
just it's a bit of a struggle
um talking although I can't say I'm sick
cuz my wife was say oh you're so sickly
but uh I'm not feeling well but anyway I
I wanted to talk about crude going back
to uh the early morning where was
it so here you got a ratio and
Divergence you do come off a little bit
it's it's 2: in the morning it's a
little bit early okay fair enough um you
know maybe you're not interested and
taking it but you know I wanted to talk
about this this was quite interesting um
again you know people that know me know
me I'm a big fan of Delta and you see
you come up into these highs Delta is
getting weaker 3 32153 at the high
negative strong negative then it turns
back you know neutral seven starts
getting stronger again and then you you
make another move up and you this is the
beauty of it you know you could just
sort of track it you know it's not
always as as beautiful as this we're
sort of coming up into the high getting
weak okay then you see it the weakness
dying out and the buying come back in
again and going back up you know I mean
you could just sort of track it if you
were to draw a line it would look you
know like that look like a
snake and you know same thing up here
yeah at this High look how we're coming
up into the high 582 187 146 make the
turn up here 146 negative here
afterwards 187 500 would you be looking
you
know at this point you should be looking
to get short all right you're coming up
here buying is definitely weakening up
you know 600 500 500 180 140 Red
Bar you know the next bar negative Delta
you know I'd be interested to sell you
could sell up here you know at 4932 that
area that'd be a great sell and what it
do it just goes down down
down you know at what point you know
down you know from 32 from the 30s all
the way down to you know below 10 so
quick say a quick but that's a 10cent 20
cent move in 10
minutes um this is Delta scoper gave a
cell didn't work
out then again you know you do have this
stacked buying imbalance on the high I
think that's a stop induced one um
failed Divergence failed Divergence two
of them boom
boom um you get to this High here again
like I just said watch these
Deltas 571 452 164 then boom strong
negative and then the selling just Falls
over strong strong selling 400 400 700
again you could be getting short you
know even if you're late and getting
short at 49 50 you know it's a move down
into the
20s you know it's not all the time you
get you know like you know patterns like
that in the Delta a lot of times it's
choppy just like this you know big small
small small big whatever not much going
on but you know watch these things at
highs of days lows of days and you know
make your decisions off that so here it
gets a little interesting this is the
Delta scalper this cell I don't think
you should be taking this cell you can
you get a nice little 10c move there by
here just sort of go sideways on
you um going down into the you know 2:00
area you know before we end up the
day and get into the night
session um you know let's talk about
this snps again snps
you know we're getting up here near our
contract highs in on the uh June
contract uh cash I believe cash made a
new a new
High um but what I thought was
interesting was this move going into the
highs up here okay
8 the high I'm interested in is this
High 2400 which is a high that we have
been testing a few times last week and
look as you're getting up there very
strong buying coming even got the
imbalance es boom and you stop right
there stop yet failed imbalance failed
Inbal uh failed Divergence failed
Divergence but you come up here
imbalance imbalance imbalance imbalance
very good volume coming up here 6,000
3,000 2,000
2600 so you got two failed divergences
get another new high
here and then you get another fail
Divergent at this point it's like I do
think we're going to go Highs but you
got to be careful it this is an area
right it's sort of it's new territory I
say even though we did hit it a couple
weeks ago but essentially it's new
territory we hit it we sold off um a
couple weeks
ago or last week feels like two weeks
ago but so I do know there's going to be
resistance up here so I'd be very
careful getting short
or because you know it might come off
and test it again might come off and
test it again now here you got the high
up here at 2402 and a qu you got a
Divergence no ratio here you got the
Delta scalper given a sell then you get
down here you got a buy and it sort of
goes sideways a little bit below it the
level come back up it's in a tight range
you know honestly you're looking at
10:00
until you know here 1:00 and basically
you're trading between
98 and a half and you know
02 so it's about a fourpoint range here
you get Delta scalper giv another buy it
does pop up a little bit going into the
cash close you get nice uh stacked in
Balance but and where are we right now
you know it's still trading around 23.99
and a half but you know
these how how to say it you know even
though you have you look at the range
right and you see oh the low is here at
88 really you should be looking at the
most recent range you know go back to
the European open if you go back to the
European open basically your what's your
low
91 you 91 91 in a quarter or you did dip
down
but for the cash session you know very
tight range very tight range so you're
not going to have big moves on on days
where you have tight
ranges anyway my cough keeps coming back
um I'm going I'll I'll finish this
presentation I
think it's just just uh a bit hard for
me to talk but let me before I do there
just one other thing I wanted to point
out this is the transition indicator
yeah was a nice day today on the
transition this is the mini da 100 range
chart again going back to the cash open
I don't Advocate trading the da you know
at at 1: in the morning 2 in the morning
you trade it when the
Dow the Dow index is open so when you're
going to get real moves
anyway um 830 here got the sell here
again I don't Advocate taking that
because it didn't go any lower after the
signal bar here this is what I like you
get your signal bar here and you can see
we start trading higher that's what you
want so you know even if you took this
you got stopped out okay that's a nice
buy this is another buy but you probably
still be long
get get a sell here get a buy there Sell
Here
by excuse
me this one you probably wouldn't have
been taken this one you probably would
have but it just sort of went pearshaped
on you and went nowhere if you took
it you know maybe it stop you out maybe
You' just you know take a break even or
take a loss on it I don't know but there
was there were some very nice trads in
here you could have had you know it's
almost picking almost I say it's picking
every turning point but you know it's
picking these areas where there's
there's nice turns in the market you
know that's that's what you want as a
Trader again I don't want you to take in
this and using it as a red light green
light system read what's happening in
the market let the market take you in
you know if you're getting a Buy Signal
or a sell signal like here you're
getting the cell signal just blow this
up real
quick okay this is your signal bar right
here right next Bar opens up trades back
up okay you know what you should really
be doing is let it Lead You In you know
the low of this bar you know you should
be getting in here you know put a stop
in for your entry people don't
understand that they think stops are
only used to get out a lot of people use
stops to get into the
market and you know that's where it
comes in you know okay if it trades here
29 20, 92 I'm in or 9003 I'm in it
doesn't you know you're not the Market's
not taking you in it's just reversing on
you so again you know it's up to you
whether you want to take those or not um
I let like let the market take me in I
like to let it confirm to me that you
know the move is
underway but you know that that's
me okay so anyway guys um you know
thanks for watching this and I've got a
a webinar coming up this Thursday if uh
you haven't subscribed to it on one of
my previous videos there's a link there
you can subscribe I'll throw throw the
link in the description as well I'd
appreciate if you could sign up and uh
attend the webinar so thanks everyone
bye-bye